welcome back to the Rich Eisen show not
to my listeners and viewers but to this
very dear friend of mine
a host of football night in America also
a voice of Notre Dame football who will
be there as a fan this weekend because
the man lives right in the area of the
big house my name is uh Rich Eisen and I
approve this message here's Mike Tirico
on this program how are you Mike
Rich yes it's a rare Notre Dame game in
person for me where I get to use my
Michigan season tickets I have season
tickets to Michigan and go to almost no
games so it's a very healthy healthy
relationship I have with your University
and it's funny Fowler will be calling
the game right just like he did last
week with Michigan and Penn State and
right you know my emotions are in play
they just flat out and play Mike you
know what do you think what do you think
you know that the Michigan story is
almost superseding the last game on the
schedule for the rivalry I'm sure
they'll figure out a way that squeeze
each other in here along the way again
it was nice when you saw this every year
it's hard scheduling wise to do it for
both sides the way college football
schedules have gone but you know the
overriding theme continues to be well
what's gonna happen at Michigan I don't
know what the biggest fault is of the
Harbaugh year and at this point other
than you haven't won their rivalry games
win the big 10 I think that I think it
keeps coming back to develop a
quarterback that's what everybody
expected and you have not seen these
star quarterbacks that are dominating
college football be a product of Jim
Harbaugh's time at Michigan and that's
probably led the biggest seeds all the
discomfort around the program right now
well we had Charles Woodson on the show
yesterday and you know Charles was in
town couple weeks ago cuz he got yeah
you know he was in the Michigan Sports
Hall of Fame which is as as a lock as
anything as anything's ever been and I
asked him you know yesterday about the
fact that Harbaugh had to send or felt
that the need to send a letter to
recruit saying all the rumors of him
kicking the tires on the NFL or vice
versa or
false and you know and he said normally
when a coach does that that makes me
think that there is some smoke there and
I was kind of stunned that Charles said
that he said he didn't get that sense
being around the team but I'm wondering
what you thought what do you think you
know I I think he's as committed to this
job as anybody can be and and I'm gonna
give you the non football reasons why I
I think young family kids are going to
school at the same school he went to the
school he grew up going to he is roots
in the community are pretty deep and
strong and I think he wants to be there
he goes past the statue of one of the
two you know performative people in his
life both sham Bechtler everyday when he
goes into his office big statue outside
the football the admission and the other
ones his dad Jack was right there
family's right there mom and dad are
living right near them he's got
everything you could ever ask for at
this point and then let me flip over the
NFL side what has Michigan done in the
Harbaugh tenure that an NFL owner is
going to say hey let's do this I don't
think there's much I think there are
four or five other current college
coaches who right now are hot with Jim
Harbaugh very good at San Francisco with
Kaepernick yes he was that's a lifetime
ago in on the field football the most
recent examples we've seen has not
duplicated that I don't know if an NFL
team was gonna say will be better
because of what he did five years ago
with the team that got to the Super Bowl
I just don't don't know if that's the
case Mike Tirico here on the Rich Eisen
show let's get to this game is Notre
Dame a better team this year than they
were last year you know rich I don't
necessarily think I'm ready to say it's
a better team I think it shall be a
better team I don't think they're better
right now and here's why I thought they
had some pretty good guys on the
defensive side of the ball last year who
went to the NFL who they've yet to
replace I think on the offensive side of
the ball they've had injuries so we
haven't seen them grow just yet so what
I think they could be fully
I thought last year's team had
established who it was by this point
this year's is still but I think they
can be now I know they went to Georgia
and lost last year they were undefeated
so out of hand I should say the answer
to that is no they can't be that good I
think they can play with anybody in the
country anywhere in the country I really
do I just don't know if this team is
going to hit its max in the second half
of the season
it's a tough test for Michigan there's
no doubt about it the fact that Notre
Dame went to Georgia rich and played a
terrific game is giving them full
conferences they go to Ann Arbor that
they could do the same thing and and
just the the the same thing that you
know I take out of what happened in Penn
State in Michigan last week right here
where you know Harbaugh has been saying
that the Michigan offense is so close
and it does appear right at the offense
arrived in the second half of that
whiteout game last week in in in in
Happy Valley so my question for you is
do you think this offense we would
actually score on on Notre Dame do you
do you have any comments on for sure no
III think they can I think Notre Dame's
defense the defensive coordinator Clark
Lee is a tremendous coach I really like
what he's done with their defense they
don't give you the same look week in
week out and they have done a lot of a
lot of different options to get to
defensively as I level Clark does but I
will agree with you that I think I've
seen most of Michigan's significant
games you know maybe I missed the first
half of the Middle Tennessee State game
but by and large that's the best their
offenses look against the quality
opponent the second half at Penn State
so did they find something that matched
with Penn State defensive scheme or did
this often start to click and find
itself I've heard other people say this
and I agree I don't know what the
Michigan offense is yet and I think
that's a part of a lot of these offenses
in football you're trying to do a little
spread you're trying to do a little read
option you're trying to do a little
empty in five wide sirs all the other
stuff same time Harbaugh wants to get in
third and one and line up big fullback
and run inside there and be a physical
team well because of the number of hours
and because of the town of college
players it's
to be everything so I think if they find
what they do best and settle it to that
a little bit they'll continue to grow
Mike Tirico here on the Rich Eisen show
last question for you on this what about
Brian Kelly and Notre Dame where
obviously you know you're very
well-versed on what's going on with
Michigan and Harbaugh as well as what's
going on with Brian Kelly in Notre Dame
where we are seeing the in year in year
out Alabama and Clemson and Ohio State
and of course you know Oklahoma and we
could say the same for five teams in six
seven teams and Notre Dame is right
there on the periphery but they haven't
broken through to a national
championship game is there fatigue going
on in South Bend best you can tell there
as well no no no there's not fatigue I
think there's pleasure that Notre Dame
has returned back to the group that is
right there with those other schools you
mentioned in that no notch below the
Alabama's the Clemson's all those
schools that get there on a regular
basis that's a little bit different
calculus for Notre Dame I I'm gonna take
a step back I think this playoff year in
college football is damaging college
football more that it's helping it
because I think once teams lose the
games it up okay your season's over
Thanks take care thanks for playing
you know and we've turned college
football into a semi-pro football and
while that's exciting while it's fun to
have this constant conversation in
October oh oh they were out of the
playoffs for this is that reason it does
not at all mesh with what college
football has been about for a long time
I think if we elevate it back to eight
teams make the playoffs yep it keeps
every conference alive damn straight
that was my response is that that's the
answer to what you're saying is eight
teams eight teams and this year I could
see it in the middle of September that
there was enough right to competition
where an eight seed or seven seed could
do some damage in the first round
against someone like Alabama or Clemson
absolutely Mike there's no doubt it's
not it's not it's not healthy for the
sport to have teams out in September in
the conversation so to your point about
Notre Dame you know Notre Dame is
interesting because the academic part of
who you can get to play football there
is
still very significant if you take the
top 300 players in the country Notre
Dame can't recruit all 300 there's not
gonna get them in school there's no
place to hide them academically so
you've gotta go maybe at half that list
and then you're still competing in some
of the best schools in the country and I
think Brian Kelly has found the sweet
spot of the expectations of the job the
academic requirements that come with
recruiting football players there and
playing winning football after the four
and eight season they've been
exceptional
and they've only lost two terrific teams
on the road or a neutral sites does that
satisfy Notre Dame alums no they'd like
to be in the championship picture
they're right on the periphery and I'd
say if they can continue this every
couple of years the mix will be right to
sell the chance to be one of those guys
in one of those big games few more
minutes left with Mike Tirico here on
the Rich Eisen show put your football
night in America hat on your head the
best teams in the NFL AFC and NFC I can
kind of guess we it's crazy I mean it
really is remarkable money it's
unbelievable rich I hope we don't tire
of it we are seeing the greatest stretch
of football by an organization in the
free agency era and maybe in the history
and of the history of the game going
back to fifties and sixties we really
are and sometimes will tire of it or
we'll look for you know the little
slight scratch in the Mona Lisa here and
this is what they do is great they bring
in they bring in players and make them
better and if they don't make them
better they move on and get the next set
of players who will make them better
what they're doing defensively this year
is ridiculous how good it is especially
in the secondary in a so the sport went
where the sport went spread and pass so
Bill Belichick went where let's get all
these great defensive backs in here
guess what their numbers are obscene in
terms of the opposing past now they
haven't played the best passers in the
league let's see how they hold up when
they play better passing offenses but I
just love watching them I really do it's
an appreciation for me football wise
over in the NFC you know
San Francisco has done it ten points and
three games here there's they have for
the next five at home I love everything
they're doing but the Green Bay thing
has a little magic tool we'll see them
Sunday night against Kansas City
Erin seems you saw rich the scene in the
locker room yeah with the players
celebrating with Aaron Rodgers have you
seen that last four or five years no no
it really is it really is working there
I know and he said in Charles Woodson
said he told Charles that right the
defense is what is giving him kind of a
second wind and that he doesn't feel
like he needs to carry the entire load
not just on the field but in terms of
captaincy is what he says you know seven
seven sacks in six games but he's
protected he has time to show his
greatness again as opposed to run for
his life on every snap the defense
that's giving him shorter field
he's giving him opportunities to win
games without having a score 40 points a
running game an established running game
put all those together and truly at the
prime of his career in that intersection
of incredible physical talent and the
mental capacity of I've seen everything
I know how to do the right thing at the
right moment I think we're seeing the
best of Aaron I really do and that again
there's no disrespect to San Francisco I
love what Kyle has done out there I
think their defense is formidable I
think there are a half dozen teams in
the NFC that I could sit with you right
now and say can I see them in Miami at
the Super Bowl yeah absolutely I can I'm
in Minnesota to do the game tonight on
Westwood one radio and the Vikings are
one of those teams - hey they've got
they've got all the pieces so I think
that NFC run is gonna be fascinating
they're gonna be a couple of good teams
that get kept out of the playoffs but
right now if you had to ask me it's New
England it's Green Bay yeah Wow and man
here you're in that game tonight do you
just you're just always on the go
brother okay I'm sorry I mean you're
you're you're a hero you're a hero Mike
Tirico it's amazing hey your you're
going to London to do games for the
second time struck so easy it's amazing
hey before before I let you go
I know you were in Bristol for the 40th
anniversary for ESPN and part of that
ceremony I don't know if you missed the
way I celebrated it out here Mike I had
an entire third hour guests come into my
studio and we ended the hour by having
him mixed martinis and clinking glasses
and the guest was named Craig Kilborn
Mike I heard about that I I've seen I've
seen killers Instagram that was a great
that was a great blast from the past it
was a good reminder I I texted be Craig
Randall
two years ago three years ago I heard
right back from that I just it just
takes us back to you know how you know
you don't know what you have or the team
you're part of right why you're doing it
and then when you look at you Craig and
the success that he had a whole
different world Robin Roberts were along
Good Morning America every day Charlie
do with it Rogers right so on I we go on
and on forever and you know God rest his
soul Stewart you know who don't fall got
to work with so close live man at what
time and and how lucky we are here we
are know some cases 15 20 20 plus later
and we still all see each other and get
that special feeling it is it's pretty
cool I know Ravi did a lot of the field
is life-changing for all of us yeah I
know Ravi did a lot did you ever do a
feel good with Craig did you ever do a
Kilbourne Tirico feel-good edition did I
ever happen oh oh I did my shirt shows
with Craig where Craig would ask for the
NBA highlights and you know you'd want
him to do it because it would make your
night did you glass slash your tail off
yeah the chrismyers Kilbourne rabi Linda
you they a whole bunch of a group of
people who you just seem to smile and
laugh with oh man like 20 years ago we
were like exchanging highlights if you
got the leads I know you got the lead
okay this game swift removals and man
that was it was for sure yeah I had our
friend producer Gus Ramsey come up with
the five questions for gray and he Craig
slipped right back in is like riding a
bike asked him
like what's that time of year where
people do you know sneeze and make
jumpers and he said it's the cold and
pure season he nailed it the cold the
cold and poo season and all right Mike
take care of yourself I know you're on
the run I appreciate the time we'll chat
soon and enjoy the game tonight and
obviously Saturday - Mike Tirico on
Twitter and at Mike Tirico NBC on
Instagram right here on the Rich Eisen
show for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app